what they would say is they wanted us to
lead
because they don't want to follow russia
they don't want to follow china they do
see us as the moral authority there and
you know it's perfect example is when
trump finally um you know when
syria crossed the red line and did
chemical weapons
and trump did the first shots back and
and did the missiles
the number of ambassadors that came to
me and said it's so good to see the
united states lead again
i'm dave rubin and believe it or not
people i am live in studio
with a guest she is the former governor
of south carolina the former
u.s ambassador to the un the author
of the book right here in my hands right
now
and a real human being i can't believe
it nikki haley fun
it's great to be with you thank you so
much i mean first we just got to do this
part i mean we're sitting just a few
feet away from each other i have not
done a live interview in person
since july my last one was ted cruz so
you got to follow up ted cruz
we'll see how that goes but just to sit
with another person
oh it's so nice right i mean we've been
through a lot the country's been through
a lot but i think the country can't wait
to just be
open again and be moving and you know
start to live life again
yeah are you shocked how long
it's been i mean a year and a half later
it was two weeks to flatten the curve
and here we are
i mean i think if you had told us all
this was going to happen
you know prior to 20 nobody would have
believed it but to really see
all the forces at play you know the fear
tactics the idea that they
you know keeping kids from school the
masks the
you know just the over exaggeration of
everything i hope it's taught a lesson
which is look we all want to keep people
safe we all want to do our part
but there is a role that government has
and there's a role that government
doesn't and the idea that
that small businesses um that we lost
thousands of them
through this the idea that people were
not allowed to make their own decisions
that's a real mistake and we shouldn't
let that happen again
so as a conservative do you think in a
weird way as terrible as this has all
been this has been the best
argument for sort of small government
policies that people are kind of waking
up
look we're here in la right now in
california you know my feelings about
this place
uh that that real world examples have
sort of led people
i think to fall more in the conservative
bucket look i think we have to see this
for the opportunity it is it was a
reminder that
states should be able to control what
happens
you know in terms of laws we don't need
the federal government man dating down
states know their people best if you
look at you know whether it was georgia
when they were the first ones to open up
and people were screaming about it a
governor knows where their hot spots are
a governor knows which areas they have
to be careful of so
allowing governors to decide that but if
you look at the states that stayed open
versus the states that closed down you
had more deaths in the states that
closed down i mean there is something to
personal responsibility and when i was
governor
i always thought when we had hurricanes
you you educate
you give people the facts then let them
make the best decision for them and
their families government doesn't need
to make that decision for them and this
was a real lesson during covet of
you know there it does go too far and
when you watch the economy and what
we've been through and the number of
people out of work and the small
businesses that have closed
didn't have to happen that way yeah so
you don't think that governors should
just pick
arbitrary dates like june 15th as gavin
newsom who is now being recalled should
do
you don't think that was the best idea i
think it's pretty crazy
i mean i i really do i think that the
idea that well first of all i think he
uh knows a recall is on the way
right right right you think it has a
little something like that needs to open
up
but um yeah no i mean i think look
people
can make good decisions i still believe
in the goodness of people i still
believe that they are perfectly capable
of knowing what's best for their
children and their families
and what they're willing to do and
government needs to just move out of the
way it's always been that way
and any i mean people have to remember
government breaks more than it fixes
always has what did ronald reagan say
the worst what was it the worst eight
words i'm going to slightly butcher it
i'm from the government and i'm here to
help you
pretty much that's where okay i know we
could do we could probably
do an hour and a half just on covet and
all that stuff but you sent out a tweet
yesterday in the midst of this john
kerry
firestorm that is erupting right now so
i actually want to read the tweet and
then we'll give a little context to what
happened
uh you said this is disgusting on many
levels biden and kerry have to answer
what for why kerry
would be tipping off iran the number one
sponsor of terror
while stabbing one of our greatest
partners israel in the back
and what this is in reference to is
audio has leaked
of the foreign secretary of iran
basically saying that then secretary of
state john kerry
told him about israeli strikes in syria
this seems like a massive scandal but in
the 24 hours since it got out there like
yeah the right
is talking about it but pretty much
nobody mainstream nobody on the left
but this seems big to me it is big i
mean biden and kerry have to answer for
this i mean this
is you know first of all if it's true
this he can't i mean it's leaked audio
of the foreign secretary
he can't be in the national security
council he shouldn't be a cabinet member
biden should answer for it kerry should
answer
i happen to believe it and the reason i
happen to believe it is kerry and zarif
were very close they worked on the iran
deal together obama and kerry never
liked israel they basically stabbed
israel in the back even after the
election was over
and the u.n at the security council and
so the idea that you would go
and support and help our number one
state sponsor of terror around the world
but stab our friend israel in the back
is
as unconscionable as anything i can
imagine but it's so
typical of the obama 2.0 it's so typical
and i think it's dangerous and i don't
trust carrie i don't trust him
to not have done this i don't trust
biden to make carrie answer for it
and i think we still have to be loud
about it because this is not okay
what do you make generally of john kerry
because it seems like he's gotten
pretty much everything wrong forever
there's videos that go viral every now
and again
of just like all the things that he has
said that he has just predicted
to be wrong i mean i just think you know
he was the one that said
peace in the middle east would only
happen that went through the
palestinians you know he
he felt like that we had to be in the
iran deal because otherwise bad things
were happening yet
when i questioned him on it i said you
know
you knew that this deal wasn't going to
last long you knew that within 10 years
they'd be
you know doing nuclear warheads again
and he said well yeah we just knew it
was a stall tactic well stalling is not
okay fixing is the way to do it and so
you know even if it's biden getting on
this electric bike you know after he
gets off his private plane it's just
hypocritical at best and that's why
i don't think we can trust him that's
why i think anything that he
gets involved in he's an elitist he's an
elitist liberal
who thinks he knows better than
everybody else and talks down to
everyone
right well there's that that video of
when he was getting on his private jet
he said well i have important business
to do
that's why i can be on a private jet not
you peons you guys are all just doing
nothing right
it's just it's so hypocritical and it's
i mean the idea when we all heard john
kerry was going to be back
in the cabinet in the national security
council i think we all took a breath
back
because we knew how much he wanted that
iran deal
and even though he supposedly you know
the climate envoy
he's going to always be weighing in on
all issues of iran that's why i think
biden needs to answer for it
this is really serious stuff but do you
think the media will do anything i mean
that that
partly you know i talk on the show all
the time now about that we're basically
just in this reality war
it's like half the people will see that
story and be like oh there's something
here
and then the other half just won't see
it and then it's like well now we're
just fighting over what's actually true
it's the reason nobody trusts media
anymore i mean why should you you're
getting one side of the story you go to
any cable network
and you're getting what they think you
know on one side or the other
what happened to the days where you just
gave us the facts and we decided what we
wanted to think
and i think the days of those are gone
so you'll never see cnn talking about
carrie doing this
you'll never see msnbc talking about it
and you know i think we still have to be
loud i think we have to push it but it's
the same thing with the border and kamal
at the border
you know we can talk about how many days
she hasn't been there but
you know even though you know they're
uncomfortable with the situation they
won't say anything well when they cover
it they'll say republicans pounce
right that's what they always say oh
republicans pounce on the thing that we
should have been talking about
all right uh let's let's shift away from
that and we'll come back to like
straight up politics and all that stuff
but i just thought for a second we could
just talk a little bit about just like
your family history and just like
the stuff that people don't really know
um
so what's the nikki haley story that
that people don't know
give me give me the bio in south
carolina
small rural town two stoplights um
you couldn't think about something you
know doing something wrong without
somebody telling your mom
we were the only indian family in that
small southern town we weren't white
enough to be white we weren't black
enough to be black
and your parents were first generation
yes my father wore turban he still does
to this day my mother wore
sorry they didn't know who we were what
we were while we were there
and i remember when i would get teased
on the playground and i would come home
my mom would say your job is not to show
them how you're different
your job is to show them how you're
similar and it's amazing how that lesson
i learned on the playground at five
played out in my life
in the corporate world as governor as
ambassador because when you're faced
with a challenge
if you first talk about the things you
have in common everybody lets their
guard down
then you can go in and start working on
a solution
yeah so technically you are a
brownish-skinned
woman but you are a scary conservative
to the mainstream do you find that
frustrating that you don't get that
little bit of bonus credit that they
might give to you if you were a democrat
you know it's
it's it's always kind of been tough when
i was elected governor
um there was a conservative that called
me a [ __ ] and there was a democrat
that said i was just a conservative with
a tan
i mean you know it's never enough for
anyone but the thing is
minorities in particular get really
offended
yeah when there's a minority that's a
conservative and so
yeah we fight battles from from all
sides but at the end of the day you have
to stay true to yourself
and you have to you know talk about what
you believe and i feel like
that through my life even though there's
been hate
from different sides if you push for the
right thing
you know people see that and so you
think that american dream it kind of
works if you
if you play by the rules it's why i get
so upset when they say we're a racist
country
i mean did we have racial issues when i
was growing up yes
but that's the same state that allowed
my dad to be a professor that's the same
state that supported my mom and her
small business it's the same state that
allowed me to be governor
you know it's the country that allowed
me to be ambassador and i'm one of
millions of
cases like that where only in this
country can you do or be
anything you want to be and government
will stay out of your way yeah and you
know
at least for now that we go we have to
make sure we're always
but you know even being at the united
nations it's there's something amazing
when countries would come and be
amazed at how we had freedom of speech
and freedom of religion and
the opportunities awarded regardless of
where you were born and raised
that's special and that's why it bothers
me so much when people criticize america
we are the best country in the world
hands down
and we have to fight for her it's worth
fighting for
because when you see the countries i've
seen and you've been the places i've
been
you'd never complain again if you saw
them are you shocked that it feels like
so many people are kind of
folding right now and just being like oh
this
this thing whatever it is wokeness
marxism
cancel culture it's just encroaching and
encroaching and it doesn't seem like a
lot of people are fighting and you've
been fighting for a long time
we'll get to the un stuff in a little
bit i wish they could see what i've seen
if you've been to the democratic
republic of congo if you've
you know where they use rape as a weapon
of war when you've been to south sudan
where
i've sat with crying mothers whose
babies were taken from their arms and
thrown into fires
when you've been on the simon boulevard
bridge watching thousands of venezuelans
holding the babies in their hands
for hours in the sun to go get the one
meal they might get that day
you know my husband's a combat veteran
he served in afghanistan
and he said i wish people in america
could just spend one day in afghanistan
because they even the homeless here have
it better than what they have in
afghanistan
that's what i want people to remember is
you know even on our worst day
we are blessed to live in america do you
sense we're suffering from our own
success in a weird way then
i think we're taking a lot for granted
there's a reason if you look at if you
speak with legal
immigrants they are in some ways so much
more patriotic
than people that were born here because
they get it they get what's on the other
side
what i want us to remember is we're not
perfect
we're a work in progress but boy we've
gotten it better than
any other country and the second you let
this woke culture and this cancel
culture start
bullying people out of what they believe
and what they think
and what they want to do to succeed
don't tear down the one part of us
that's so
great that other countries envy us for
it
yet here we are and we're we're here and
you know what this
elections have consequences um and we're
feeling the burn but sometimes you have
to feel the burn to know where up is and
and we got to start looking up we got to
start pulling out and we
this is not the time to whine this is
not the time to complain or get lazy
this is a time to fight this is the time
we fight back
we push back for what we believe in and
be proud
be proud of this country because it's
given us so much
and there's so much more it's going to
give our kids and our grandkids
all right so that that probably could
have been your closing statement but i'm
not letting you out that easy
so let's let's back up for a little bit
when did you decide to go into politics
and i guess more importantly why did you
decide to go into policy
i was never that political kid i never
cared about politics
in high school i was never in student
government not in college republicans
i had um started doing the books for my
family business when i was 13. and
didn't know that wasn't normal until i
went to college
but really when times were tough i
learned how to stretch a dollar i had to
figure out what we were going to pay
and what we weren't and when times were
good we never celebrated because you
knew bad times were going to happen
again
ended up going to clemson go tigers
graduated with a degree in accounting
and then worked
for a company and six of its
subsidiaries is the accounting
supervisor
and then i got tired of working for the
guys down the hall and so
we came back home to the family business
and one day i was complaining to my mom
about how hard it was to make a dollar
and how easy it was for government to
take it
and she said quit complaining about it
do something about it
i did not know you weren't supposed to
run against a 30-year income at the
primary
i truly didn't ignorance is bliss but
once
i realized he was related to half the
district and i had thrown my head in
the only option was to win so my husband
got in the driver's seat
i was in the passenger seat we put our
two little ones in the back seat and i
started knocking on doors
and was able to win that statehouse seat
and truly it was
i thought there were way too many
lawyers at the state house and they
needed a really good accountant
yeah so then that was just the beginning
of your political career really so when
did you
decide to take the next step so
interestingly enough
in south carolina legislative votes they
counted legislative votes by
voice vote all in favor say aye all
opposed
the eyes have it but one day there was a
piece of legislation that was read
across the desk that would give
legislators pay raises
all in favor say aye all opposed silence
and they passed it and yet to this day
you can't find one legislator that said
they voted themselves a pay raise
republicans you don't say republican
house republican
senate i went to our republican speaker
of the house and i said this
is why people don't trust us and i filed
a piece of i filed some legislation that
said
anything important enough to be debated
on the floor of the house or the senate
is important enough for people to have
votes on the record
so the speaker pulled me aside and he
said put the bill away
we don't need to have it we will decide
what the public needs to see and what
they don't
and i remember going to my husband that
night saying if i can't even get
legislative votes on the record what am
i doing here
and he said then fight so i went around
the state of south carolina
and said did you know of all the bills
passed in the house only eight percent
are on the record
did you know of all the bills passed in
the senate only one percent was on the
record
so if you didn't know how your house
member voted 92 percent of the time
if you didn't know how your senator
voted 99 of the time
how did you know who to vote for when
you went to the polls the people of
south carolina were shocked
now to put this into perspective my
first year in office i was chairman of
the freshman class
my second year i was majority whip my
third year i was on a powerful business
committee my fourth year i was
subcommittee chair of banking
the year that i didn't put the bill away
they stripped me of
everything wow i was completely
blackballed i could take the well
no one would listen i could sponsor a
bill
no one would co-sponsor so i ran for
governor
and one of the first bills we signed
into law is now in south carolina
everything debated on the floor in the
house and the senate has to have a vote
on the record and we took it a step
further and did
every section of the budget as well and
you had a pretty solid record
in south carolina you're pretty proud of
that right that's very proud i mean
we went from a 13 unemployment rate to
the fact that south carolina didn't have
any industry
all our jobs were in the textile market
and they had all gone overseas
and we had to wake south carolina up and
so i went in there and said if you're
costing a person or business time you're
costing them money that's no longer
acceptable in south carolina
and we got to work and by the time i
left we were building planes with boeing
more bmws than any place in the world
five international tire companies
the largest carbon fiber producer in the
world
they were referring to us as the beast
of the southeast and i loved it and
no unions i was a union buster the whole
time if there was a company that wanted
to come in
that was unionized we we strong-armed
them and said we don't want you
so what would you say your guiding
political principles are because it's
interesting to me like
you're 13 years old doing the books so
like there's numbers and those things
matter and now we live in this bizarre
time where everyone's like
2 trillion for this and i just saw this
morning they want they want to pass
another 80 billion to fortify the irs
like what like does anyone look at math
anymore did
calculators exist like what's going on
here but
but did you have a sort of guiding
political principle like when did that
sort of all come together
i mean i really think at 13. i mean i
learned the value of a dollar
yeah and i learned that that dollar you
can only stretch it so far
and so really understanding the value of
a dollar
appreciating small and limited
government so that people can be
successful without government
getting in the way understanding the
importance of a good education
and that education not being government
responding to money
but government actually responding to
kids and allowing families to decide
their education
and then allowing job creators to do
what they do best which is create jobs
you know if you give a small business if
small business
makes money they don't go on vacation
they hire more people
and so the goal is you want small
businesses to have cash flow so they can
spread the tentacles out
and do that you want a strong foreign
policy where you're
you know making sure you're safe
overseas and it's not coming here
these are basic principles it's not
rocket science
but it's core values that i think are at
the heart of the republican party
but they're at the heart of a good
america too if we do it right
yeah so what was it like the day you got
the call let's flash forward a little
bit the day you get the call
would you like to be the ambassador to
the u.n i can only imagine because it's
there's a very legion of doom scary
feeling over at the universe
the thing people don't know is donald
trump and i knew each other before
when i won the primary for governor the
first time
i got this envelope with this great gold
trim
and in it was a support check and there
was a note that said you're a winner
and so i got on the phone and we chatted
and we um
were acquaintances throughout the years
and then 2016 happened
and um we had a great slate of talent
on that stage i put my name behind a
different horse
um wait who'd you back originally rubio
okay and then
that's when trump tweeted um nikki
haley's embarrassment to south carolina
and i turned around and tweeted bless
your heart so
we always had a great respect for i knew
if you kicked him
he kicked back he knew if you punched me
i punched back
and so there was a respect there and but
after the primary i
i threw all my support behind him and he
won so
when we got the call reince priebus said
he wants to talk to you about
um you know us he said don't say
anything u.s
ambassador to the united nations i said
right i don't even know what the united
nations does i just know everybody hates
it
yeah yeah and so he said well he's going
to call you so when he called me
he said all right nick are you going to
do this and i said well
i said there'd have to be some changes
and he said what i said well
i've been a governor i don't want to
work for anyone else i would want to
work directly with you so i'd want to be
a cabinet member
he said done i said well i'm a policy
girl so i'd want to be in the room when
decisions are made
so i'd want to be on the national
security council he said done
i said well i'm not going to be a
wallflower or a talking head i need to
be able to say what i think
and he said nikki that's exactly why i
want you to do this and he was true to
his word from the first day to the last
day we had a great working relationship
so what was it like going into the u.n
because i think you just described it
perfectly i mean it seems like the most
backwards at least the security council
stuff i know they do some i suppose they
do
some good humanitarian stuff maybe uh
you can you can comment
i don't know you all right well you can
comment on that obviously but like to
just go in there and have to
and try to at least defend freedom try
to get some of these
insane votes that they're constantly
doing reversed and change some of that
stuff like
i'm guessing you were walking down the
hallway people were not like oh yay
there's nikki haley
i mean it was the u.n is not for the
faint at heart
i mean every day it felt like i was
putting on body armor and
you knew we'd have a fight you just
didn't know which country we were
fighting that day
but how blessed was i to defend the
country i love so much
and i was not gonna let them criticize
us about anything i
purposely went in not knowing the do's
and don'ts of the un
because i wanted to kind of be able to
ask for forgiveness and
and really go in with fresh eyes but i
also knew i wanted to be very black and
white i wanted to make sure they knew
what the united states was for and what
we were against and there was no gray
area i didn't care if they liked me
but i wanted them to respect america and
i wanted them to know where we stood
obama had really created this scenario
where
they didn't know what we were for you
know when he tried to appease everybody
by criticizing the u.s
and he would just throw foreign aid out
to everyone to buy friends
i didn't want any of that i wanted to
make sure that we really put
our line down in the sand of this is
where we are if you want to join us we
will partner with you
and if you don't we're going to call you
out for it and so that's why i said we
were taking names at the u.n
they thought that was like unbelievable
that i would say something so
undiplomatic
yeah but the point was if you go around
saying death to america we're going to
take down names
but if you're our friend and ally we're
going to have your back and take down
names and protect you too and so
look it was a great experience it was
it's challenging to deal with the
chinese and
and to have the russians always trying
to stir the pot and to have everybody
talk negatively about america
but i wasn't going to stand for it i
went and take one second of it um
because i know how great we are and i
knew what they were telling me in the
quarters of how great we were yeah so
that that's actually exactly what i
wanted to ask you so like
i would imagine that the countries
secretly believe that most of the
countries like they secretly must be
like yeah if the u.s doesn't exist in
freedom
then we're all kind of screwed but then
they rarely vote that way or
publicly they say all these oh they
basically just publicly but what they
would say
is they wanted us to lead because they
don't want to follow russia they don't
want to
follow china they do see us as the moral
authority
there and you know it's perfect example
is when trump finally
um you know when syria crossed the red
line and did chemical weapons
um and trump did the first shots back
and and did the missiles
the number of ambassadors that came to
me and said it's so good to see the
united states lead again
like they that's what they want they
want us to call out evil
they want us to do good they want us to
show something and that's why i've
always said the united states
leadership isn't going to war sometimes
just when the leaders
just when the united states says
something countries follow
you know when we mention this is what
should happen they do
tend to move with us and so there's good
that we have there but we have to
continue to use that voice and be a
force for good can you explain you
either your philosophy or
trump's philosophy or both of your
philosophies just generally on when
you should use the military because i
think a lot of people think
somehow if you if you're for the
military that means you're for war
that's the case actually the reverse
yeah i mean the key is look i'm
i'm in a military family so the last
thing i'm going to say is with my
brother was full-time military
my husband is the last thing you want
your family members to go to war
but the military's there for a reason
and
what you do want is for example you know
with biden wanting to pull out of
afghanistan well my husband served in
afghanistan
i know what was happening there we don't
need thousands of troops there but you
do need
some there for intel purposes that's
really what you want is military for
intelligence
to tell you on the ground in syria
whether they're getting ready to do a
chemical weapons attack to tell you on
the ground in afghanistan
whether there's another plot for 9 11.
so
the only thing i'll say is that biden's
foreign policy is really backwards in
the way that
look at how much has changed from the
chinese delegation comes to alaska and
humiliates our american delegation
you know putin's challenging biden to a
debate how
ridiculous is that kim is starting to
test off ballistic missiles again
and here biden's falling all over
himself to do business with iran but his
boycotting georgia
you know like these things and then all
georgia the state not george or the
country
absolutely and all these things amy's
cutting our defense spending
you know i'll be the first one to say
the military's bloated it's bureaucratic
there's a lot that we shouldn't be
paying for but if we don't modernize our
military
china and russia are already moving iran
is already speeding up
we look so distracted right now and
making sure we modernize our military
making sure we have strategic military
on the ground in certain places to keep
us safe
and to keep bad actors from doing more
harm that's an important thing
so what do you think is behind biden and
the decisions he's making this is the
question that everyone gets asked all
the time like because i think most
people
don't really believe it's biden leading
this thing anymore that it's either
the obama machine behind it or something
that's left of the clinton machine or
something else altogether like to me it
seems like if you would have asked joe
biden 10 years ago
if he agreed or disagreed with some of
the things you just said there he
probably would have agreed where now
it's like
who knows what he believes what it feels
like to me coming
you know in the transition from obama
obama to the trump administration and
foreign policy and now where it's going
it really does feel like obama 2.0 i
mean the idea that they're already
trying to make friends with iran that
was very much something obama would do
you know the idea that they're like
starting to you know
pick fights with russia in a strong man
sense but not in real results since
that's something obama would do you know
the paris climate agreement the human
rights council all these things
these trump reversals are very much
obama's stances
and so i think that that's the approach
biden's taken he surrounded himself by
obama people whether it's
you know secretary blanken or jake
sullivan or any of those those are all
obama people that would be advising him
on what obama wants
so what can be done at the international
level like with the u.n at this point
like
if you were there right now which
probably ain't gonna happen but if you
were there right now i mean
this this just in the last couple days
iran got put on the
the was it the women's rights council
they're leading
council i mean how ridiculous is that
well like are these people laughing it
was also china like this is like an
absurd
but who makes these decisions like
there's a like someone goes into a
meeting and they're like yes yes let's
put her on on the
on the women's rights council like like
how does that even happen
it's why the united nations doesn't have
credibility it's why they struggle
first of all if i was at the united
nations right now i would immediately
call a security council hearing
and hold china accountable for what they
did to the world with covid
i would ask what the world health
organization knew i would call out
iran for all of the violations of u.n
resolutions that they're doing and say
how can you turn around and get into an
iran deal when they're violating
multiple
resolutions um you know there's a lot of
things that could be done and should be
done and instead what we've seen is the
u.n ambassador
went and basically criticized america
was there was there any speech that you
had heard in the last couple years that
was more
awful than that mortified that here i
was
defending america and here
the chinese delegation goes and
humiliates the american delegation
and the u.n ambassador basically gave
them all the fuel to do it
yeah you know i mean you don't go in we
are not a racist country we are the
least racist country and so the idea
that they would
say that is it's such a i can't even
understand what
biden or the ambassador think that will
do to help america
that doesn't that's apologizing for
america i don't think they want to help
america at this point that's what i mean
about biden i don't know what biden
believes but i think the machine that's
under him or behind him or whatever it
is like it was do they want to help
america
it made it made me sad i mean you talked
about what is
what can the u.n do what is it good for
the reason
presidents struggle with staying in the
u.n is not because
of any great actions by the u.n we see
that all the time
i think the reason they stay is because
of the veto there are only five
countries that have a veto on the
security council in the u.n
russia china u.s u.k
who am i missing france so
if you look at those if bad things
happen if russia and china try and
get together and do something bad the
u.s can stop it
that's the reason that we're on the
security council is
we can stop bad things from happening
but they waste more than they should
ever
i cut three billion dollars the first
year off of that budget and that was
just low-hanging
and the lights didn't go out the
building still existed and people see
that big building and they think they're
ambassadors in there that's all staff
yeah they've got elevator operators in
there
i would say do you know how many
vaccines you could give kids with what
you're paying these elevator operators
they doubled their staff in the last 10
years and don't they didn't wasn't there
some massive scandal where they were
like racking up something like 100
million dollars worth of parking tickets
in new york city like it's just crazy
over there so ridiculous and china is
infiltrating the entire u.n they are
trying to really
i think they now control four different
agencies within the u.n
russia controls the cyber agency believe
it or not china almost
started controlling the intellectual
property and we were able to stop that
from happening but
i mean it's just the un will not be
relevant until they start talking about
the things that are uncomfortable to
talk about
the uyghur genocide that's happening in
china you know
the fact that they won't even have a
meeting about it they won't even do it
yeah
yeah so what do we do with china because
or what do we do with china but
what like are we on some inevitable
collision no matter what here like just
because of debt if nothing else like if
they just call
in hey guys you got to pay us back for
some of this stuff and then it's like
well we can't we don't have the money
and we do have missiles and bombs
it's actually pretty scary what's
happening right now because china is our
number one
foreign policy threat but the concern i
have is
america looks so distracted right now
yeah like
everything all these countries see us as
distracted but china
is in this for the long haul and the us
at some point has to quit thinking about
things in terms of presidential
elections
we've got to start thinking 20 and 30
years out what does our foreign policy
look like
if you look at china they have the
largest naval fleet in the world they
have more missiles than we do now
they're building up their military
we've got to start modernizing ours they
are continuing to steal intellectual
property we've got to start holding them
accountable
for every time they steal that
intellectual property but what does that
actually mean though like because what
do we have at this point beyond the
threat of military action like we're not
bombing china tomorrow probably like
look
sanctions and stopping business with
china is a big deal to them
humiliating them and calling them out is
a big deal they have a million
muslim uighurs that are in concentration
camps this
is if you saw what was happening there
it's horrific
it's rape it's sexual abuse it's
physical abuse it's for
slave labor i mean making them change
their name change their religion drink
alcohol for the first time just to break
them
i mean it's a horrible situation we
swore
years ago never again would we turn our
eyes away from genocide and it's
happening right now and no one is
calling china out for it it's the reason
why i think it's so important that we
boycott the chinese olympics
is because in the last olympics the way
beijing looked at it was the last one
that they hosted
was their coming out party this one mark
my words
this one is them saying we are the new
superpower of the world
and after that olympics they will go and
try and take taiwan
and if they take taiwan that's a total
game changer around the world
and so they're trying to get as much
good press as they can
if we call them out they hate that so
making sure that we call them out on
genocide making sure that we hold that
we actually hold them accountable
accountable on intellectual property
modernizing our military which scares
them
or having a military presence anywhere
scares them
um you go and you look at what president
xi did he started a commission
that basically said any company that
does business with china
has to cooperate with our chinese
military now think about our tech
companies
think about all the information they
have on our habits on our
pharmaceuticals on everything we do and
now know the chinese military has access
to that
think about that like that's dangerous
and we watched this play out in real
time with kovid
that when we were trying to save
millions of lives
what was china doing they called two
american companies 3m and honeywell who
have business in china
said you were not allowed to sell any of
your ppe
they bought it wholesale and they would
only give it to countries
that agreed to do business with huawei
their 5g network
this is a country that is out to
really take over the world and do all
that that's what all these investments
around the world are
is when they're running up this debt
then they go and they say to these old
countries okay give us your military
installation
give us your utility and the debt that
we are in
is the first time our debt is bigger
than our economy since world war ii do
you know what that does
makes china so happy because when you
weaken the dollar like that
that's a national security threat beyond
anything else
there's a reason china and iran just got
into a bank together
is they're trying to make sure that the
u.s dollar is no longer the world
reserve
and we're sitting back and watching this
happen
and not doing anything about it so do
you think no one in the administration
gets it because i think most people
watching this are probably even if
they're not that in the weeds on all
this they're probably like yeah that
does feel like
basically what's happening that china is
saying we're going to be the new
superpower and they're setting up all
the pieces
in play but do you think anyone do you
think the administration cares
i think the u.s is playing the symptoms
so they see what china's doing they're
treating
like symptoms but they're not treating
the disease
that china is a disease that we have to
stop thinking if we're nice to them
which kerry just said
oh we should be nice with china so we
can cooperate on on the environment
we have to stop thinking if you're nice
to china don't want to be like us they
don't
want to be like us they want to be
communist they're going to continue to
do whatever it takes they're laughing at
us right now
what we have to do is let china know
we're on to them and we have to act
accordingly
now that doesn't mean that you know they
can't buy
grains and poultry from us or we can't
buy t-shirts and light bulbs from them
but it does mean they don't get to
control our pharmaceuticals
we don't need to go in so much debt that
they own us like there's certain things
we just need to be smart about strategic
about instead of just curing the little
symptoms that come up along the way do
you think part of the problem with some
of this stuff is that now and i think
you were alluding to this that now some
of
our conversation is about race it's
about all of this internal stuff here
and wokeness and cancer culture and all
this
but the idea of this big problem that
like sits there is just like people are
just like oh
i don't know like we got enough problems
here even though i think in many ways
our problems here are completely
fabricated
we do have big problems here and we do
have big problems overseas
we should be able to handle both at the
same time like it's not an either
saying we could do two things at once i
mean it's it's you know there's
something to be said for
balance and prioritizing and making sure
that everything
is in its order you know and you talked
about the race aspect
i mean one of the things that was so
appalling to me is what happened with
the georgia bill
you know south carolina when i was
governor we passed voter id in 2011.
much tougher than the one georgia did
and i said at the time
if you have to show picture id to buy
sudafed if you have to show picture id
to get on a plane you should have to
show picture id to protect
the election process i was vilified at
the time they said that i was trying to
disenfranchise voters
that you know a lot of people couldn't
get picture ids and i said okay fine
if that's the case i will send someone
we will pick you up
we will take you to the dmv we will get
you a free picture id and we will return
you home
i know the number so i'm going to set
yep how many people went in on that
program
five million people 25 25 people
asked for a ride the number of people
that now vote in south carolina is
higher
the part that was so offensive don't
assume minorities
can't get a picture idea don't assume we
can't go get a picture id don't assume
we can't pick the schools we want our
kids to go to
it's actually democrats that are racist
that treat us
like we are inferior incapable
and it's offensive on so many different
levels
well it's also specifically racist to
black people because even though you're
saying we you know they don't mean
indian people right like that's part of
the odd position that indians are now in
that indian americans are now
as a successful minority but look at
this so they're sitting there and
they're
they're going through all this stop
asian hate all of this
but why was it the democrats that shot
down the part that said stop
discrimination of asians in schools
just in the last couple days i mean you
know so it's just hypocritical in terms
of what they think is racist and what's
not you know
when you're brown it's almost worse
because they think you're not black
enough
or you don't count or you know they can
discriminate against you in schools but
hey don't
don't mess with them when they're trying
to vote all of these things but
all of that does is it assumes
minorities are dumb
and it assumes minorities are less than
and it's democrats that are doing that
and we have to keep calling them out on
how racist they are
they see what too many republicans do
too many white republicans frankly do is
when they call you racist they just back
down
they go into a corner don't do that
we're not racist
it's the reason why i'll say this until
my last breath is
we are not a racist country do we have
some bad eggs
always but so does everyone else but we
have progressed over the years
over and over again you can see it
through all the things on how
women are empowered on minorities are
empowered everything people have
been lifted up in total that's what you
want to continue to see happening
how badly did the republicans just screw
up the messaging on this like do you
have any sense of sort of when it
happened because as
as a guy that's kind of new to this side
let's say the right or the conservatives
whatever it is
i went to a ton of trump rallies i've
been to anti-lockdown rallies
i've spoken at turning point usa things
i have
never once i swear to you ever heard
anything
remotely racist ever
and in q and a's when someone might ask
a question that could kind of sound that
way
they shoot them down i mean i never but
it's like how did republicans just
become
such wet paper bags and just fold over
this it's actually what democrats did so
when democrats ran out of excuses they
started saying that they were racist
it and they immediately saw republicans
cower yeah they immediately saw
republicans cower
the thing is republicans are too nice
they're too nice like is it nice or is
it just thinking that the government's
not the answer so you just
you just don't want to be in that fight
in a way that they do they're too nice
like you fight
back yeah if you know you're not racist
say you're not racist if you know we're
a good country say we're a good country
don't let them yell us down because
we're the ones that are right
so go back and fight for it and that's
the only part is i don't want people to
get tired
we don't have time to get tired we have
to get strong and we have to fight back
because if you let them get away with
this they will only continue to do it
more and more i mean look at what has
happened
because of this racist conversation the
idea that we've gotten into defunding
the police
the idea that you want to now hold
police officers
liable these are the kinds of things but
they're doing it all in the name of
racism
and there's a miscommunication there i
do think and by the way they're
reversing it right after they do it
right portland is now reversing a lot of
the policies
absolutely and look i do think that race
is
an important issue in america it's one
that needs to be dealt with with respect
it's one that needs to be understood and
it's one that you need to have a
a good conversation that's educated and
respectful
that can move the ball and there's a
time and place for that i had to do that
in south carolina multiple times
but when it shouted down and done in
judgment
that's not good will that's just sitting
there fighting to fight
so this is my million dollar question
then with that in mind what do you think
the future
of the republican party looks like
because i've been saying something for a
few months now that in essence right now
the
war let's say is sort of woke or
conservative and i don't mean
conservative meaning
you have to have a picture of ronald
reagan next to your bed but that
you're we know what woke is and then
it's sort of
everybody else and we can disagree on
tax rates and i think we can actually
disagree
on abortion and a slew of different
things but what do you think that
that big chunk actually looks like like
what kind of diversity
in a political sense can we get out of
that so what i would like to think
that the republican party will be is it
won't go
back to the party before trump because
that was a really important move that we
made
um so many people like where i grew up
in rural south carolina who felt
unheard misunderstood um not paid
attention to
suddenly came into the fold and they
made our party better
the problem is we lost women we lost the
suburbs but more importantly we have to
expand our tent
we've got to reach out to hispanics
we've got to reach out to the jewish
community we've got to reach out
to asians and make sure that we have
that conversation
african americans i did it in south
carolina it can be done
but you don't go to them and say you
should be one of us
you go to them and say what do you care
about yeah and when you have that
conversation
suddenly they realize you care about the
same things
and then you have a conversation i know
if i went and spoke to
several hundred indian americans right
now 70 would be democrat
but if i just showed up with respect
had a conversation we'd win half of them
it takes more work
it takes more time it takes more effort
but if we do it we will be a better
party
do you know we've lost the last seven
out of eight popular votes
for president that means we're doing
something wrong
if we grow our tent if we grow our party
we will be a stronger country and we
will be able to move the ball
not for the next presidential election
but for 20 and 30 years down the road
we have to do it do you think some of
that stuff can actually be healed like
right now and you can't judge things by
twitter i know that much but there does
seem to be this like tension between
whatever the sort of magga camp is and
then
the pre-mag of people and it's like how
do you get these people to kind of
like you seem to me to be like a kind of
like
like a synthesis of those things well
like how do you do it because there
seems to be a lot of resentment from the
mega people
to the old ones and then the old ones to
the maga people and the whole thing i
mean i think the first thing is
the judgment has to stop yeah there's
way too much judgment
of people there's an unforgiving side of
just toxicity that's happening right now
and so what i think we have to
understand is every day joe biden and
kamala harris are in office is another
day we should come together
but we are better together you can fight
each other all you want it is not
productive we are better together we
have a bigger enemy out there
and that's socialism and it's going to
happen if we sit there and keep fighting
all it's going to do is open the door to
socialism and we're gonna end up having
to walk right through it
and then we won't have time to go back
and say oh we should have so
come together i respect both sides you
know
it it goes back to um
in south carolina when we removed the
confederate flag you know we had had a
terrible tragedy it was a tough time
and in that removal of the confederate
flag when i called for it to be removed
i was very aware of two things half of
the state
saw the flag as heritage and ancestry
the other half of the state saw it as
hate my job wasn't to judge either side
my job was to get them and move the ball
forward
and so when you take judgment out
then all of a sudden people's defenses
are not there then they
listen and i worry right now that
there's a lot of judgment going back and
forth
don't shoot your sisters and your
brothers we're in this together we're
one big family and we've got to move
forward
but we move forward in the conservative
ideals that we all hold dear we move
forward because we know socialism is bad
we move forward because we know big
government's bad we move forward because
fiscal responsibility matters
and all of those things can work
together if we if we're on the same page
what kind of pushback did you get from
your own people when you started talking
about the flag after
charlottesville a lot yeah a lot um you
know i
i think that look any time you do
something
you're never going to please 100 of the
people and that can't be why you do it
you do it because you can see something
bigger
and a better place forward for all
people and so
you know south carolinians were many
that were very upset with me that i did
that
but at the end of the day south
carolina's better state for it
and they saw that afterwards and we
didn't have riots
um we had vigils we didn't have protests
or we had hugs
i mean we did it in a way that the
national media
didn't tear us down we did it in a way
that was respectful we did it in a way
that moved the ball
and that's you know what you have to do
there was another um a month prior to
the church shooting
we had the shooting of walter scott
killed shot seven times in the back
unarmed black man this was right after
ferguson
i just was so worried our state would
fall apart
the first thing i did was call the
walter scott family and say we will get
answers for you
if you will allow me this time i will
get you everything you need to know and
we will make sure his life wasn't in
vain
the next call i made was to law
enforcement saying we've got to fix this
let's do this together a month to the
day
south carolina passed the first body
camera bill in the country
and when i signed that bill i had the
scott family on one side and i said
never again will a dirty cop
do to someone without us having proof
and then i had law enforcement on the
other side and i said never again will a
good cop
be accused of something bad
you have to be willing to see the
greater good
and you have to be willing i mean one
leadership is
not letting the two sides kill each
other not letting the two sides blame
each other
but getting the two sides to understand
we all are trying better for better
things and that means we all got to give
a little
do you think oddly that a lot of the
democrats now are doing the complete
reverse which is sort of nodding to the
violence that we're seeing on the
streets and they don't mind
when this chaos is erupting it's a real
problem
i mean when you go it doesn't make sense
when you have
these violent protests and you're
tearing down
you know an african-american small
business or you're seeing
an african-american police officer shot
like these things you're hurting your
own people
i mean at the end of the day the
protests and the violence if you're
upset i get it
i get it but do it productively in a way
that we move the ball
you know because hurting the community
you know whatever color you are
that's not moving the ball that's only
hurting more people but are you shocked
are you shocked that no democrats i mean
really
no democrats are joe biden is still only
saying antifa is an idea
an idea that's caused about two billion
dollars worth of damage no i think that
they
fail to see what they don't want to see
and they
immediately judge and go after what they
want to assume is the culprit
and it's it's it's harmful for our
country and something has to change
and you know our job is again not to sit
back and say
it's done we can't do anything no you
keep saying something you keep
correcting them
and do it unapologetically do it with
courage do it with strength and do it
with passion because when you do that
they don't have the standing to really
keep going because if you were to
question what's racist and what's not
or question protests and they can't say
more than a second sentence because they
have no other
explanation after that that's kind of
why they're into that censorship thing
too
there's a little something to that so to
that point we sort of touch on this but
one of the reasons that i came around on
trump was i
saw that it wasn't just republicans
fighting democrats it was republicans
versus democrats and the media
and he was just like i'm not going to
take it what do you think republicans
can do
in that fight because i get a lot i hear
a lot of people now that are really
regretting my
few good liberal friends that'll still
talk to me they're not happy with biden
but what they're saying is we still had
to get rid of
trump because of his you know the way he
spoke and all that kind of stuff
but to me it was like he knew how to
fight that thing and you're not going to
get the perfect guy to do that
like what do you think republicans can
do like you can see them doing this with
desantis now though that awful 60
minutes
hit piece and everything else like what
do you think republicans can do in that
arena because that's not the political
arena that's more the media
i mean i think we've seen look i've been
hit recently by a liberal reporter that
will go out and they'll do profiles and
they'll try and shoot you down
they're going to go out you talk about
that political piece i read it this
morning that was like
we'll post i don't even want to give
them don't give them i don't want to
give them the clicks but
but i read it this morning the first
paragraph alone well first off it's
fiction
they actually write it as a fiction
story there were so many untruths in
that
story but that was meant to be a hit job
yeah they knew exactly it didn't matter
what i said
they wanted to fit it into their
narrative and that's what the media does
is
they take it and they've already got the
story written before you say the first
word
and what we have to do is call it out
and say
this is a lie this is wrong you know
whatever but boy do we have to keep
pushing back and
again that's why the media is not
trusted but it's a real
problem it's a real problem because
there's more me liberal outlets
than there are conservative outlets and
so the liberal outlets anyone that they
think is starting to rise or get a
louder voice
they're going to shoot you down and
they're going to find some way to do it
i don't want to link to the piece but
maybe we'll put an
image up or something from the piece
because it was so extraordinary i mean
it's literally written as fiction
and you know the amazing thing because
it's hard to it's hard to really make me
be like whoa
at this point because i've been through
it but like i was really not only that
95
of what i said about trump was good and
he was angry about it
he was competitive about it and then the
five percent that i said
related they acted like i woke up with
an epiphany that something happened
the problem with articles like that is
they are
trying to change the political dynamic
on their own
they're trying to create the story on
their own because they know the
democrats don't have a bench
they know that they don't have strength
behind them so they think the best way
to do is just tear
everybody down and do it in different
ways and we're watching it happen to all
of our republicans
they'll just tear you down one at a time
they'll find some way to do it
and i don't know what the answer is i
just know that we don't cave we keep
fighting
do you think that basically
conservatives and again i mean that in
sort of the wide sense of it just have
to start building completely new things
i mean this is sort of a new idea that's
out there now which is like
in essence conservatives will have to
have their own banks they'll have to
have their own places of
journalism they'll have to have their
own educational institutions
you know that that at some level these
things are just irreparably damaged
and we should just let them have it and
the rest of us will build better things
i mean i don't know that it's
irreparably damaged i mean i think that
the media misses trump terribly
i think they're so bored i mean i was in
course the airport the other day and a
reporter is chasing me down the airport
and i'm like this is what you have
left you know i mean i think the the
idea is they miss his tweeting
they missed the stories because it
provided something every day and their
ratings went through the roof
now their ratings are not going through
the roof people are watching less news
because they're tired of it
people are not getting as much benefit
from it because there's no substance
it's more opinion
than it is facts and i think people are
done but i do think
conservatives should support
conservatives right
whether it's businesses whether it's you
know
media outlets whether it's something
else or whether it's creating your own
is don't feel like you have to deal with
it let's find ways to make our own side
better let's find ways
to fix it so when i've talked to my
let's say left-leaning friends about
this new conservative movement the two
that still get them
it's always the same too it's abortion
and belief
that most of them come not that they're
all purely
atheists but they have this real thing
about oh the right is just too
religious or something like that so
could you kind of soothe them perhaps on
on either one of those my example i'll
just tell you is
well rudy giuliani is obviously a
conservative and he was obviously a
trump supporter
and not only when he got divorced oh
because then they'll also say the gay
thing a little bit which i think the
ship has settled on well
he lived with two gay guys after he got
divorced he's pro-choice
and he was a trump supporter so it's
like nobody's doubting that he's a
conservative
so i see a wider tent there
what could what would you say about that
look i mean i think we all have our
views
and i think again lack of judgment is
important as you go forward i just um
i don't believe in in being a judgmental
person i don't think anybody else should
should allow them to go into that
negative energy either but
look i mean conservatives are you know
i'm a person of deep faith i think that
um god has blessed us in so many ways
but i use mine
as you know it's like my parents always
said you know the best way to appreciate
your blessings is to give back
so it's more of like a service that you
feel that you give back
if you've been blessed with goods you
try and pass it on you try and hold the
ladder down you try and help other
people
and you know that um that there's a
higher power
some people don't believe in that and
that's okay you know that's
that's not you know something that i
would ever judge someone for it same
thing with the pro-life i'm pro-life not
because the republican party tells me to
be
but because my husband was adopted and
i'm blessed every day for him
and so i think experiences are what form
us but at the end of the day we have to
look at the greater good
right and figure out how we get there
and so
i also don't think we're all one issue
people i mean the way the democrats
always assume women are so divided on
the pro-choice issue
they're so for women but i always
they're not for nikki haley
i mean so for women you know for black
people they're not for candace owens i
mean my thing is like
that's just ludicrous to think that one
issue should make or break us
you know i don't agree with my husband
100 of the time doesn't mean that i
don't well you know
i mean and i think that you know any
time they try and one issue us off
that's again desperation to do that yeah
do you think part of this is
is sort of just the politics as religion
that something has shifted
in the way we talk about politics now
that everything is political
everywhere you know i don't watch i got
a basketball behind me i don't watch the
nba anymore
because i could i partly was because of
the china thing i'm watching lebron
won't say a word about china
and they have black lives matter on the
court and
yeah yeah what do you think about it i
think politics has gotten
too involved in everything and that's
the thing is i feel like
it's all about sound bites and it's not
about substance anymore
so people are just spouting off things
that are hateful i don't know if covet
exacerbated that i don't know
you know whether it's social media
that's done it but people are so
quick to say hateful things but they
won't do it in person yet
right right but they will do it through
the media they'll do it paul got one of
these yeah
they'll do it in every other way um so i
do hope that calms down
i mean you know politics should never be
100 of anyone's life
you know i always politics for a lot of
years may have been my
job but i never took it home i have
friends that are democrats i have
friends
that have different views than i do i
have i watch movies with actors that are
democrats you know i'm not one of those
that says you can only listen to
you know conservative musicians i mean i
i
appreciate all of those things i think
there's a place for politics
and i think that's at the voting booth
and i think that's in making sure that
you're supporting candidates and that's
making sure that you're moving the ball
on policy
but the rest don't forget to love your
neighbor it still matters
gosh i really forgot how much i love
just sitting across from somebody and
not staring into a screen all the time
so before i ask you the one that you
probably don't want to be asked the last
question
i didn't look at my notes this entire
time i was with you the whole time
is there anything else that you want to
get off your chest perhaps at the moment
anything else that's on your mind before
i get to that question that you know i'm
going to ask that you probably don't
want me to
i just want everybody to remember how
blessed we are
and we've just gone through what was a
traumatic year
um you know from school closings to
maskings to deaths to
you know everything in between but that
doesn't mean we have to sink down with
it
i think we can rise up above that we
just showed how resilient we are
again we just showed that at operation
warp speed that they found a vaccine in
less than a year
we just showed the goodness of our first
responders like
so much good and blessings came out of
it take that energy and let's
let's carry that forward don't let all
this negativity and everything else
bring us down because we've got a lot of
work to do
that could have been something 22 we got
a lot of ah 2022 i want to talk about
two years after that
for a second you know i have to ask i
have to ask what
come on come on give me something it'll
go viral i just don't think i have to
make that decision yet
i don't i don't i think that the way i
look at i've never been one that's
thought too far out
but i do think 2022 is really important
we have to win the house i think we can
win the senate i'm an optimist we've got
to win some governor's races we've got
virginia and new jersey up
um this year and so i think there's a
lot of work to be done
i think that i don't have to make a
decision before then
and i think afterwards we'll kind of see
where the chips you know fall but it's
not something that i
you know grew up saying oh i have to do
this oh i have a family
you know you think twice about it when
you have a family you think twice about
it when you know other people
will be affected and it's not you know
politics is a blood sport it's not fun
right now it's you know it's a tough
time to be in it
right but right now i feel like i can do
the greatest good by making sure we win
the house and the senate back and so
we're campaigning here we're going to be
campaigning for michelle steele and
young kim
we've endorsed marionette miller meeks
and julia letlow from
louisiana we're going to be helping
candidates all over the country and
we're going to try and recruit some
really good ones because
the ones that won um you know in this
past congressional races
man they're good quality people i mean
they're going to run circles around
nancy pelosi and we need more of that
all right well ambassador governor
undeclared presidential candidate nikki
those are moments in time it was a it
was a pleasure it was just so nice it
was so nice to talk to you and actually
seeing a person again
oh this is a great time thanks for
having me well thank you so much we are
not going to link to that political
piece
down below but we will link to nikki's
book
with all due respect which i've got
right here and we'll do more of these in
person wow all right
why not if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell